et aujourd'hui c'est avec bilal tarab et
bonjour bilal bonjour florent vous allez
me parler bien sûr de l'ukraine qui fait
la une de nombreux quotidiens c'est le
cas depuis le 24 février dernier
absolument et c'est le journal le monde
ce matin qui se concentre sur le volet
diplomatique de cette guerre avec un
dossier titre et l'impasse du dialogue
macron poutine est en phase iii le
quotidien dresse ce constat le tandem
franco allemand est à la peine emmanuel
macron et olaf scholz manque d'autorité
selon le journal depuis le début de la
guerre parce qu'ils sont supplantées par
l'engagement très volontariste je cite
des états unis et le retour en force de
l'otan ça ça arrange bien les états
d'europe centrale et les états baltes
totalement alignée sur les positions
américaines et surtout convaincu plus
que jamais que le ce que seul le
parapluie américain peut assurer leur
sécurité l'article de rappeler que olaf
scholz emmanuel macron sont toujours
attendus à kiev même son cloche 1 à
vladmir poutine il ne change pas son
fusil d'épaulé il présente toujours
cette guerre contre l'ukraine comme un
conflit de civilisations contre
l'occident finalement tout à fait sauf
qu' un petit problème c'est que la
propre fille de vladimir poutine semble
faire partie de ces russes qui aime
beaucoup beaucoup l'occident une enquête
du guardian britannique révèle que
catherine attire nova s'est rendu en
allemagne plus de 140 fois ces deux
dernières années où elle entretiendrait
une liaison avec un danseur de ballet
qui s'appelle et je vous le donne en
mille igor zelensky le hasard fait bien
les choses voilà rien à voir avec le
président ukrainien il est russe a
beaucoup de dettes détracteurs du régime
russe dénoncent eux le culte de la
personnalité autour de la dmr poutine en
prenant part légalement depuis des
semaines il le forme il semble que ce
n'est pas propre uniquement à la russie
en tout cas tout à fait ça se passe aux
etats unis aussi le washington post
affirme que le parti républicain n'est
plus je le cite en parti politique au
sens traditionnel du terme mais une
organisation qui pratiquent un culte de
la personnalité et qui repose sur un
programme matinée de théories du complot
or le culte de la personnalité c'est
donald ray la théorie du complot c'est
que la dernière présidentielle élection
présidentielle a été volé et si le
quotidien américain on parle ce matin
c'est parce qu'il ya les élections de mi
mandat les midterms en novembre où la
participation est généralement moins
forte car la présidentielle le
washington post conclut juge si nous
pouvons rejeté le trump isme sa religion
son début de fascisme trois petits
points tant qu'on le peut encore donc un
appel aux américains pour aller voter on
reste aux états unis mais sur les
réseaux sociaux cette fois ci oui cette
alerte d'abord du new york times de plus
en plus de jeunes achètent des
anxiolytiques sur les réseaux sociaux
est malheureusement en meurent selon un
magistrat californien les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus l'endroit où se
fournir dans avec ces pilules mais au
delà de consommer ces médicaments sans
ordonnance 1 il s'agit la plupart du
temps de faux de contrefaçon qui
contiennent un équivalent de l'héroïne
qui s'appelle le fentanyl et les
plateformes commences ta réagir juste
pour vous donner un chiffre 1 sur les
six derniers mois rien que sur snapshots
nachat a retiré
144000 comptent eux liés à de la revente
de cette drogue des réseaux sociaux qui
vont peut-être supplanter la presse
people oui j'imagine que vous avez
entendu parler du procès en cours johnny
depp et son ex-femme en bearer de n'en a
pas entendu parler voilà c'est un petit
peu difficile déjà le procès est diffusé
en direct sur youtube mais il est
surtout présent sur le réseau tik tok et
le monde ce matin titre la tabloïd
isation de tik tok avec tout d'abord un
constat c'est que la multitude de conti
découpe analyse comment tu racontes ce
procès s'apparente en réalité un travail
de production de séries télévisées et de
masse un je vous donne un autre chiffre
le nombre de clics sur le hashtag justin
fort johnny depp qui est donc en faveur
de l'acteur ces 12 milliards 400
millions de clics un problème de taille
qui est un de ses corollaires c'est que
bien évidemment la justice populaire
s'exprime à travers
les réseaux sociaux c'est le cas avec
une campagne de dénigrement massives
dont est victime l'actrice amber heard
qui est perçu comme la méchante un
accusé une accusée de ne pas être très
crédible voilà pour finir cher florent
cette revue de presse je vous propose un
blind test est ce que vous êtes prêts à
c'est le rêve d'une vie qui devient
réalité et ben voilà tout à fait le
premier morceau c'est parti
pour avoir déjà joué ce sujet tout à
l'heure à priori c'est vanghelis tout à
fait la musique du film les charrient
très très fort deuxième morceau
[Musique]
l'aïd runner à la décidément florent
vous êtes j'ai pas beaucoup de mérite on
a joué le sujet tout à l'heure où
j'aimais bien entendre c'est de ces deux
chansons tout à fait excellent mais il y
en a une troisième celle là va jouer
maintenant
j'ai connu ça
[Musique]
c'est tout dire bah oui
c'est le sait la musique cette fois du
film 1492 christophe colomb conquest of
paradise évidemment ces trois morceaux
iconique allons reconnaître le style
très épique du compositeur ses ventes
génisses vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
il est décédé cette nuit à paris à l'âge
de 70 ans on a des fans en régie qui
nous disent qu'il faut dire vanghelis
avant quand l'hélice alors voila mon
grecque n'est pas très bon désolé au
delà de ce que nous avons pu entendre
dans l'excellent sujet de notre collègue
marc pop sachez qu'il y a également une
planète qui a été renommé à son nom en
1995 la planète donc vangelis vanghelis
après enghien c'est être un jour là la
planète bilal tarab et qui sait où je
pense que vous aurez la vôtre bien avant
moi cher florent c'était la revue de
presse signée de l'excellent bilal tarab
et merci beaucoup merci rial